today we're going to talk about
reconstructing evolutionary trees
and the way that we're going to begin is
with a story that may not seem connected
to evolutionary trees
this looks like a pretty typical hotel
but it's actually the site of an
important moment in 21st century history
it's in hong kong and it used to be
called the metropole hotel
a chinese doctor checked into room 911
of this hotel on february 21st 2003
he had been treating patients in a rural
area of mainland china
who were suffering from a deadly
respiratory illness
and he had come to hong kong for a
wedding the next day
but when the next day came around he was
too sick to attend
and he wound up checking himself into a
hospital down the street from the hotel
two weeks later he was dead
now you're probably wondering why on
earth would i tell this sad story
so let me travel back in time to the
14th century
when the black death killed a third of
all europeans
the black death was lethal but it was
also very slow
it took four years for the black death
to travel from constantinople
or modern day istanbul to kiev
these days you could do that trip by car
in just a day
or just two hours by plane
in the 21st century though all it takes
for a disease to go
global and become a crisis on the world
scale
is for one person to travel from an
isolated place in rural china
to a business hotel in densely populated
hong kong
just on the ninth floor of the metropole
hotel
the chinese doctor infected 13 other
people from around the world
two days after he checked in the disease
was in hanoi
three days after that it crossed the
pacific to toronto
two days after that it entered singapore
in other words
the disease was a global epidemic before
anybody even realized it was a global
epidemic
in fact it was a global epidemic before
it even had a name
today we know this disease as severe
acute
respiratory syndrome or sars
so the bad news is that globalization
means that diseases travel fast in the
21st century
but there are so many zombie movies out
there on such widely varying topics as
abraham lincoln killing zombies or
zombie beavers
that i hope you already know that in the
bottom middle there was even a
sars-inspired zombie movie that was
based on star wars and called believe it
or not sars wars
that's the bad news the good news is
that we have a lot more weapons against
epidemics in the 21st century as well
researchers quickly realized that they
were dealing with a special type of
virus called a coronavirus when they
looked at sars under a microscope
why is this called a coronavirus because
when you look at it under the microscope
it looks like
the sun's corona during a solar eclipse
now coronaviruses like hiv and influenza
are rna viruses which means that they
possess rna
not dna in 2003 researchers quickly
sequenced the sars coronavirus
which makes up a genome with 29 751
nucleotides
here's a short snippet from the end of
this rna genome
now rna replication has a much higher
error rate than dna
which means that rna viruses are able to
mutate fast
this is why the flu shot changes from
year to year
and it's also why there are so many
different types of hiv
and why we don't have a vaccine for hiv
either
it's very difficult to vaccinate against
something that can mutate so quickly
here we see it's mutated just in the
time i'm talking to you
now researchers initially thought that
like hiv and influenza sars had jumped
from animals to humans they first blamed
birds because of the similarity of sars
with bird flu
a form of influenza that originated in
chickens and first crossed the species
barrier to humans in 1997.
but which animal did give us sars
how was it that we came to be infected
in the first place
and how can we reconstruct its path that
it traveled around the world
it may not seem like it immediately but
all of these questions are related to
constructing evolutionary trees
which are also commonly called
phylogenys
for example here's the first
evolutionary tree which was drawn by
charles darwin in 1837
and here's a phylogeny that's
constructed for hiv and its relatives
just from this evolutionary tree we can
infer that hiv
crossed the species barrier from monkeys
to humans
at five different places marked by stars
these five different crossings divide
hiv into five different viral families
now from this hiv diagram it should be
clear that if we want to know which
animal gave us sars
we should just construct an evolutionary
tree for the sars coronavirus
as well as coronaviruses from other
species
then we simply see where stars is
located in this tree with respect to
other coronaviruses
but the question remains though what
algorithms do we need to use in order to
construct evolutionary trees